residents at a care home in the uk are
enjoying their newfound fame
after a project where they recreated
some famous
album covers it went viral
and has caught the attention of some of
the celebrities involved i
recently had the chance to chat with the
man behind the idea
activities coordinator robert speaker
this is no
ordinary care home
[Music]
you've now become a viral sensation
how are you doing right now how are you
dealing with this moment i'm so
amazed by the response walk me through
the process of
choosing the album covers features like
the adult cover
that was almost spot on it was more
to find somebody with the same kind of
personality and character that could
match up well to the famous artist
i selected the albums that were commonly
known if you saw
the michael jackson bag for example most
people
know that album cover along with a
number of the others
and it gave me the opportunity to spend
and some quality time with them so
whilst we were photographing or getting
it all ready and
i was painting somebody's arm or face it
was a good opportunity for us to talk
just to say you know how are you doing
have you got any worries you did i mean
some classic covers
taylor swift was one of my favorites
have you heard from any of the artists
well i'm still waiting for taylor swift
and
people keep saying well what is she
doing at the moment surely she's not
that busy
so early i'm sure taylor's watching this
right now taylor we're waiting for you
we've got rini here she's waiting to see
what you think of this i love it but the
um somebody told me the lead singer of
blink182 retweeted it so he has
definitely seen it
i also have to say the clash cover i
love
that is one of my favorite poses as well
send my love to
that resident yeah that's that's sheila
she's not your classic
93 year old take me the picture rabbit
of what the moment looks like when
you're
actually shooting the cover are you
playing any of the songs from
the albums it's not many care homes
where
they have taylor swift playing as and
probably
not many that have blink 1a2 playing but
this is no ordinary care home it was
just a case of
can you just move your right hand just
slightly
slightly no not that far yeah just back
and they were then
what do you want of me and then they
would lose the whole pose and we'd have
to start again
and to be able to show them the final
piece and see their faces
and their reaction and their hysterical
laughter
at seeing themselves and their fellow
residents
in these different poses i love that
this is no
ordinary care home i saw you respond to
a tweet the other day
somebody suggested a calendar yeah a lot
of people
have suggested the calendar so i fear
there is demand for a calendar and we
hope to put one together
very soon i would be first in line for a
calendar
okay okay okay your name is down the
order right now put me down for a
calendar
what has been something that you feel
like is the greatest lesson you've
learned during this time
they have lived full lives they've lived
through world
wars they have heard all of those
artists
not many people can say they have heard
elvis
they have lived through all of that
their matriarchs
of their families and we need to take
care of the elderly
and show them the respect that they
[Music]
deserve